wow  what a turnaround and then be free look  at that  by entirely immobilizing the queenside  pawn mass i suspect b3  was something that  sam had underestimated actually that's a  rather brilliant move um yeah this is  this is fantastic and now all he needs  to do is push push push force the queen  to take and then the other pawn goes in  and i suspect that that's oh no actually  we even accelerated the the center pawns  and now by the time i catch up it's  going to probably be going into a most  chaotic ending actually let's watch this  annie danny we get a new queen on the  board but now the pawns are rolling in  is there a mate  uh i mean it doesn't really help that  sam has no time left on the clock right  i mean queen e3 is going over  oh yes because b3 is getting so yes the  answer to my question was that yes there  is a mate sir  um  quite simple one too so king b2 queen  takes here and mate